he who must not be named must have had
to wear a lot of prosthetics but little
did we know more of the work was done in
voldemort's cgi from his unique spell
casting to that infamous nose we're
showing you how they managed to pull off
that iconic look
number one we only got a tidbit of
information of how they pulled off our
first look at voldemort and looking at
it now it seems a little archaic but at
the time it scared us right out of our
seats with richard bremmer's face as the
dark lord his image was used more than
we'd think while actual prosthetics and
makeup were used to transform him the
cgi stood out like a sore thumb on this
one we think they were saving the dark
lord's return to screen for a more
advanced time and video effects
technology
number two with the second installment
of the harry potter franchise came a new
look at a past version of tom riddle
though cgi wasn't much in play in terms
of his appearance it was used to make
the beautiful magical writing but the
real cgi came into play as harry faced
off against the basilisk in the chamber
of secrets we built the first 25 feet we
could put it on a massive ram and put it
on tracks designers spent a long time
convincing director chris columbus to
allow them to use a more practical
contraption making dan's performance
more convincing i felt that a gigantic
snake needed to be mostly cgi of course
they still mixed in a little visual
effects to make it terrifying for the
audience
number three here's to the first real
glimpse at the sinister ray finds as he
who must not be named talked about so
much but never seen
and making him real it was in goblet of
fire where harry finds himself at the
hands of the new dark lord we were
confused as to what he turned out to be
he looked very human but his nose
non-existent the expectations that
people would have from the book so the
nose became very important well it was
existent for fines and visual effects
artists did wonders altering it out all
it took was an hour or two in the makeup
chair putting dots all over his face for
them to achieve the final look they were
used to
digitally remaster my
conch the veins we see on his head were
all done practically and those dots were
used to track his real nose then vanish
it in post he seems quite normal but
then you look a little close and he
writes you know what it's not quite
right
number four voldemort had a few humorous
moments in the order of the phoenix just
popping into harry's mind to say hello
we can imagine this effect was done with
simply a green screen and of course the
usual nose removal procedure the real
work comes at the end of the film which
we'll just go ahead and disappear to
number five this was definitely one of
the most epic moments in the harry
potter franchise the dark lord versus
the most powerful wizard albus
dumbledore those beautiful spells that
were cast in the duel were digitally
designed to fit the environment the
effects in the atrium had to be larger
and more spectacular than the previous
scenes special effects added in a few
pops and explosions on set to really
nail down those destructive castings
production designers spent months
creating as much of the ministry of
magic out of set materials to really
immerse the audience into the story
david wanted to feel like the wizards
were using things within the set but in
the background you can see a whole lot
of green screens making this one a
pretty hefty project for post-production
artists
you can see here we could have put in
the lens flares and things that augment
the image number six voldemort and
dumbledore pulled no punches during this
incredible duel and we cannot forget
that fiery serpent riddle pulls out of
his mouth of course the crew probably
thought it was best not to allow for any
practical effects on this one the cgi
for this was so detailed that it took a
while for them to pull this one off now
the real actor work was put in when
producers found it interesting to encase
voldemort in a ball of water one of the
things they did was set up a rig for ray
finds to sit on they had rafe stuck to a
pole in front of a blue screen flailing
his arms about seemed safe i was safe
but it took me a few takes to feel how
safe it was
number seven we always wonder what it
would be like to film something that
isn't really there or even interact with
the imaginary things but these actors
really sold the whole that's a big snake
really about to eat that muggle there
feeling and all it took was some great
acting and a nice camera move for
designers to add nagini in post we know
she's gotta eat and all but does she
really have to do it in front of
everyone else
number eight the dark lord is in full
hunt mode in the deathly hallows and
even tries ending harry in the sky while
the work was all put in by daniel
radcliffe's stunt double and some
impressive visual effects he still had
to do some work behind the scenes as
harry almost unconsciously locks spells
with voldemort we get a beautiful visual
of the impressive effects work we've
seen before
number nine as dark and ominous as this
scene was we can't help but marvel at
how it was pulled off when voldemort
breaks open the tomb of dumbledore he
finally retrieves the elder wand this
upsetting moment was created on a stage
set that stunning spell casting in the
sky was created in post to make us sit
at the edge of our seats for the end of
part 1.
number 10 we guess explosive
spellcasting was a theme for the deathly
hallows and this scene in part two
brought us right back to holding our
breaths with the grand improvisational
skills of ray finds this final blow to
hogwarts defenses made us grit our teeth
you know how spells work in posts now
and all the actors on set had to fake
the impact on this one the extra emotion
and physicality that finds brought to
the scene really brought the visual
effect to reality
number 11 this moment had us all wishing
it weren't real but unfortunately the
only unreal thing about it was the
outside this very practical set was
built with a high attention to detail
from the old wood look of the dock to
the water below and that was the grand
finale of snape
number 12. there's no need to mention
that pretty much every moment in the
final film made us incredibly anxious
for our favorite heroes and with the
moment harry faces his demise we were
not left without a ginormous visual
impact we all gasped at the shock wave
from voldemort's ending blow the one
that wasn't enough to take out our
chosen one
number 13 while a lot of the harry
potter sets were real this one in
particular incorporated a lot of cgi to
the mix with the crumbling set pieces
made out of more lightweight materials
everything else was surrounded in green
screen the dark lord came dawned in his
usual dots and of course those brows
prosthetics but that unexpected hug
voldemort gives to his little champion
made us wonder if one of those
prosthetics fell off
number 14 chaos ensues after harry fools
the dark army but he didn't fool us when
it came to the duel with voldemort
popping explosions here and there to
sell the effects of the spell casting we
were so convinced in the final film that
perhaps magic was indeed real but really
these vfx artists really know how to
sell the look
number 15 we can all agree that he who
must not be named really relished the
opportunity to go all hands with potter
they really put the actors to work on a
realistic set allowing them to do the
rest of the imagining needed we can't
fathom what feins told his friends he
did on set that day
number 16 when disappearing came to
fruition in the later films they just
kept getting better and better but we
never got to see what it was actually
like and as filmmakers pulled no punches
in this installment we got our first
look very terrifying indeed getting that
up close and personal with tom but
potter was ready to fulfill the prophecy
now how they managed to pull this one
off is a little humorous dangling those
poor stun doubles upside down in front
of a green screen is definitely no easy
task but just seeing them squirming
around during a very ominous moment just
gave us a good laugh number 17 and here
it is the final duel not much more cgi
than we've mentioned before but we
really needed to show you this wicked
cool version of how the vfx geniuses did
it
number 18 now that harry has fulfilled
his ultimate purpose voldemort had to go
out in a very dramatic way and the best
way they did it was having riddle
dissolve into ash and scream in agony
and you'll always get a good defeat
scene from a great actor even if their
emotions are cut short
number 19 on a more informational note
ray finds was actually the reason why
voldemort was part cgi i was very keen
not to have to too much makeup on
filmmakers initially wanted him to wear
prosthetics to cover up his nose but for
a seasoned actor too many prosthetics
just made the emotions harder it's
curious how you feel it blocking
expression when you wear all that stuff
in the end fein struck a deal to only
have his head tattooed with veins and
some eyebrow cover-ups we can definitely
agree that nose prosthetics are
definitely a no-go
number 20. for the final bit we'd like
to take things down a hilariously
upsetting path the moment happens as
rafe walks around set in between takes
of course wearing the appropriate dark
lord attire when a kid happens to
stumble at his side and this poor child
probably never stepped foot on that set
again i passed by this little child i
just looked at this boy he was burst
into tears voldy went through a lot of
changes in harry potter but what always
remained true for finds that terrifying
serpent knows would he have looked
better with more prosthetics let us know
in the comments